the movie starting
[Music]
I don't like the sound of them apples
whoa what are we gonna do Jackie
yeah it's hunting season applesauce
[ __ ]
[Music]
well when the dispatches has done
something wrong with Donna Cobb for
abstract the news to everyone at
Mordecai
[Music]
[Applause]
to the Barons Elance
[Music]
10 keep the change ya filthy animal to
be or not to be not to be not seeing
this film alone
he's back and this time he's mad Gandhi
- from Fox Searchlight
[Music]
Satan's now unison closer to listen hard
Paco the meth cooking here is me hanging
up the one I do that
is me pulling the trigger think you've
got a fine brain jack we come in peace
for cats and mice everywhere you're not
going to the meeting you're a baby
really thanks for telling me I forgot
for a second that I had a one-inch penis
seven o'clock psychoses Santa's workshop
need this and only Lee Majors can stop
them here we go again again sweet yes it
was
pick up your phone and call the prefer
those [ __ ]
talk about a hole-in-one chances are you
bought them already